boltzmann developed a really famous
equation
which is is this
oh
screwed that up let me start again so
what i'm writing
is s is equal to k
log
oh
sorry i'll get it red
s
is equal to k
log so that ln means natural log
of omega
very very big important symbol in
physics um it's s entropy is complicated
it's the first thing to say about it um
it's there are lots of different ways of
thinking about it there are mathematical
ways of thinking about it there are
physical ways of thinking about it and
we could think of for example with the
students here who are milled about the
milling about they're filling out this
space quite well we could think about
bringing those into what we term a low
entropy state where we pack them all
nicely together nicely ordered in the
center of this this this lovely grain
and then as they sort of uh
spread out move away from that nice
order state we say we're moving to a
higher entropy state and that's really
what entropy is about it's about this
dispersal of energy about this moving
from
a state where everything's nicely packed
and nicely tightly ordered into one
where everything spreads out and you can
apply that to gas molecules just as easy
as you can apply to students the easiest
way to think about it is it's to do with
how disordered things are
and so the greater the degree of
disorder in something the higher its
entropy um so if you have a vars that's
kind of a low entropy object if you drop
it and smash it into pieces it becomes a
higher entropy object
and the basic one of the basic laws of
thermodynamics says that in any natural
process in other words unless you try
really hard and put lots of work in
entropy will always increase so if you
drop a vars it will smash but vases
never spontaneously unsmashed themselves
you've got to define the difference
between something that's impossible and
something that's very very improbable so
it's not impossible for example for all
the atoms and molecules in the air
around us to suddenly collect themselves
together and head off there and we we
asphyxiate that's not impossible it's
just incredibly incredibly improbable
similarly it's not impossible for um
the
if you put some cream in your coffee or
some milk in your tea you know that that
those milk molecules will just spread
out and you then mix um naturally with
the tea with the water in the in the cup
it's not impossible it's just wildly
widely improbable that those molecules
could come together
and and reform a droplet in the in in
the center of the cup
so entropy is a measure of that tendency
to move away from something which is all
clumped together in relatively order out
to spread out to the molecules spread
out the energy spreads out in the system
my suspicion that s probably comes from
the german in this case because it came
from but i don't quite know what it
where why it's called this um
they it was the concept was developed by
a guy called ludwig boltzmann
a very famous
physicist who i guess started off his
days looking like johnny depp and ended
up looking like
oliver reed i guess
so that the the wonderful thing about
this particular equation or the
interesting thing about this particular
equation is that it's actually engraved
on boltzmann's tombstone although it's
not as
well recognized as for example e is
equal to m c squared
it's
arguably just as important and i'm not
going to get into the details of exactly
what those symbols mean but the
important thing is s gives us a measure
of the number of ways you can arrange
the atoms the molecules or even the
particles in a system and
when boltzmann developed this
it's i think it's fair to say that some
um elements of the scientific community
really sort of poured scorn on these
ideas um and really thought that they
were completely off the wall and really
were nonsense and this drove
boltzmann really to commit suicide which
is incredibly depressing because he was
vindicated not so many years of was
vindicated almost directly after his
death and
these
the equation and the underlying theory
is an important part of absolutely every
area of physics
every area of the physical we're not
just physics actually chemists will hold
boltzmann and all as well